- I mean, can I just lead with
you are the raddest looking human ever.
(audience applause)
Like things I dream of in my head.
I'm like I can try this,
like you pull off all of 'em.
- I just don't wanna feel
like I look in the mirror
and I look conservative and straight.
I don't know somebody like,
(laughs)
you know like, like you know,
sometimes I pass Brooks
Brothers and I think to myself,
"Well, that ain't bad," and I'm like,
"What do you mean?
"That's bad."
(laughter)
- I love, here's the thing.
- I love this place.
- I love Brooks Brothers.
- Yeah, me too.
Like, you know, like really being
in like a pinstripe suite
with like, you know.
- Yeah.
- Like my real color hair,
which I haven't seen since I was nine.
- I was gonna say,
I don't think you're ever
gonna be able to fight rock & roll.
I think that's just gonna
naturally exude from you.
That's what we love about you.
Have y'all ever met before?
- Yeah.
- We have.
- You know, on her show.
- On my show.
But I agree with you, as
soon as I look too proper,
I'm like, "Uh, uh."
- Like you know, I don't know
what older artists look like.
- Kinda like this, like just...
(audience laughter)
- Naw, you look beautiful.
You're not old.
In what age, time, realm
do you think you're in?
- No, I'm just gonna
be basic Betty though,
even at 70.
- No, no.
Like it's gonna like
when I gray up I'm gonna,
I'm cool with it.
That's who I am.
I like rollin' with this Cyndi.
(audience applause)
- What I always think of is
your song What Doesn't Kill..
- You know that song?
- I love that song.
I do.
- I'm so cool right now.
- I used to like,
whenever I was feeling
really like down trodden
I would like sing along with you.
- I love that you've even heard it.
- Are you kidding?
- That's day made, check.
- It was a huge hit.
- Oh my God, well thank you.
- Wasn't it?
- Okay, okay, it was.
(audience applause)
- All right, so tell us about your,
it's Home for the Holidays, right?
- We're coming to LA.
Usually we're in New York, but this year,
it's a special year.
We're coming to LA.
LA.
- LA.
I like how you say it.
(audience applause)
- It's our big fundraiser this year.
Well, every year.
It's the main thing we do
for the True Colors United.
It's an organization that we did to,
to help eradicate, I guess,
youth homelessness
and that ranges anywhere from 12 to 24.
And what we discovered
was that there's 3.7 million
kids on the street in one year
and up to 40% of them are LGBTQ,
which is a lesbian or gay.
And you start to realize
that a lot of these kids
are getting thrown out of their homes
as they come out to their parents.
I'm a mom.
You never get the kid,
the kid isn't who you want the kid to be,
the kid is who the kid is and as a mom...
(audience applause)
You know, you don't want
to throw your kid out.
- It's great you do that
work and I think it's so,
you know, people think it's better,
and it is, but it's not better everywhere,
and it's not better in every household.
- It's not better, it's not better
- But when better comes from the bar
that's way down here then
you've still only made it here.
- That's right.
- You've got a long way to go.
- Yeah.
- But guys, it's not.
- I mean, we've been trying,
but it's still up to 40%.
- Yeah.
- I just think that we can
do stuff with education
and different programs,
which we have been involved with.
We bring a lot of organizations together
and outreach programs together.
This is the work we do.
We lobby.
We've had people from
like 50 Cent to Laurie...
- I think Pink has done...
- Pink.
- Pink, yeah.
- Reverend Cox.
- I think what's important
too, like just to point out,
I know you're not gonna say this,
but the fact that you are
unique and you are an original
and a lot of the kids
you're probably speaking to
are unique and very original
and they stand out in their community,
the fact that you're leading it up
means all the world.
(audience applause)
Like it's not like somebody
shouting from the rooftop
that doesn't get it.
That's the key.
- Well, we can grow.
- You took your platform
though and you did something.
That's a cool thing.
- You know, you can't
throw away our youth.
Our youth is our future.
We're parents.
We stand by the kids.
We have to,
because, honestly, you won't have a future
if you don't listen to them.
(audience applause)
- That's really cool.
Well I love this.
- Saturday, come to the show.
December 10th.
- Home for the Holidays, yeah.
- I'll be there.
- All right, so where is
this concert happening?
- At the Novo Theater on December 10th.
October 18th tickets go on sale
and that's truecolorsunited.org
and get all the information.
Get information about what we do.
Together we can actually
change the situation.
- Absolutely.
And once we take care of that
40% we can move on the rest.
- To volunteer.